monsieur le président vous annonce que
je quitte mes fonctions de député de
scouting je manquerais avons d'abord
auprès des électeurs si je continue mais
sans la fougue et la détermination qui
ont marqué mon parcours grande surprise
ce matin à l'assemblée nationale à
québec voyez l'accolade avec son nouveau
chef stéphane bédard voyez le premier
ministre qui a lui aussi tenu à saluer
ce ce député qui a passé 17 ans à
l'assemblée nationale il est arrivé sous
lucien bouchard et sa femme qui elle
était peut-être soulager d'un retour à
la maison plus fréquents stéphane bédard
et sébastien beauvais on ne l'avait pas
vu aujourd'hui deux départs dans le camp
souverainiste on va parler de gilles
duceppe dans une seconde mais d'abord je
bédard faut dire à qui on avait enlevé
le rôle de leader parlementaire et on
sentait que le coeur n'y était plus
nécessairement pour monsieur bédard
depuis que pierre karl péladeau lui
avait enlevé ce poste de leader
parlementaire un poste clé à l'assemblée
nationale pour un parti politique lui
stéphane bédard il avait plutôt que la
réflexion sur son avenir politique a
commencé il ya cinq ans que à ce moment
là il se demandait s'il allait continuer
que l'élection la victoire électorale de
2012 la veille regaillardi mais que la
défaite électorale de 2014 à recréer
cette réflexion dans son esprit et
qu'elle était plus dure à encaisser que
sa rétrogradation de leader
parlementaire à critique en matière de
justice
c'est la raison pour laquelle il part
aujourd'hui avec son allocation de
transition 250 mille dollars
alors si j'avais dû partir sur une
déception sera était là dessus le reste
il va mal été houleux j'ai compris qu'il
fallait qu'elle est elle meilleure maman
est là le meilleur moment ça devient
compliqué tout ça elle et quelques nains
politiques
regardez aujourd'hui à mon ami gilles
duceppe et qui est ce que j'aurais pu
prévoir ce jeu c'est au moment où j'ai
pris ma décision sur ma pote ben
justement ils viennent le dire gilles
duceppe ou si on l'annonçait il ya
cependant grande surprise mais a
l'impression qu'il a fait ce qu'il
pouvait et puis voilà au revoir
il part avec le sentiment du devoir
accompli le bloc québécois a fait élire
ces députés à la chambre des communes
lundi dernier met pas gilles duceppe
alors il part il tourne la page sur 25
ans au bloc québécois avec le sentiment
que le parti est en ordre
écoutons monsieur duceppe comme nation
nous avons une responsabilité face à
l'histoire
à la suite de celles et de ceux qui nous
ont devancés
nous avons la responsabilité de durée de
transmettre aux prochaines générations
la fierté de faire partie de cette
nation francophone des amériques
merci alors il reste quand même de
l'incertitude sur l'avenir du bloc
québécois le parti n'est pas un parti
reconnu à la chambre des communes
c'est réal fortin qui a été élu lundi
dans la circonscription de rivière du
nord du nord c'est dans les laurentides
saint jérôme qui deviendra qu'il devient
en fait le chef intérimaire du bloc
québécois
petite ironie la saint girons pierre
karl péladeau saint-jérôme réal fortin
saint jérôme merci sébastien bonne
soirée à kipawa